the island of hispaniola here has had a
long history of unification and division
it was a series of individual states
then ruled by the spanish then it was
split with a french ruled entirely by
the french partially ruled by the
spanish and independent haitians
entirely ruled by the haitians divided
between the haitians and the haitians
followed by the independent dominicans
and the spanish again back to
independence and then to shake things up
it was occupied by the americans before
again settling down into the two modern
states of haiti in the dominican
republic which raises the question why
couldn't the island stay united so when
europeans first turned up to the island
it was divided into a number of
chiefdoms which the spanish then
promptly conquered afterwards the entire
island remained under spanish rule for
130 years when france won the eastern
third of it and france's portion of the
island would grow rapidly in wealth
until the french revolutionary wars this
was when france having defeated most of
europe won the rest of hispaniola from
spain there was soon a slave revolt in
the western third napoleon sent troops
to crush it and when that failed the
island was split again this time into
the newly independent haitian empire
with the french in the east which lasted
for a whopping two years before its
emperor jacques got himself unalived and
the country fell into civil war the two
stayed divided until 1820 when the
northern king died and the southern
republic led by jean-pierre boye
reconquered the rest by this time the
french had been kicked out of the
eastern portion of the island with the
spanish back in power and after this
there was a long-standing period of
peace and rebuilding and just kidding
the haitians invaded and bowie declared
himself dictator for life boyer ruled
over all of hispaniola for the next 20
years he paid in indemnity to france in
return for international recognition of
haiti's independence and he kicked out
all of the white landowners from the
east of the island except for the polish
that is they were cool boyer did very
little to unify the two parts of the
island culturally and many in the east
saw themselves as a wholly distinct
people from the haitians who now ruled
them and thus it was time for a calm
discussion by which i mean armed
revolution boyer fled in 1843 and in
1844 the dominican republic declared its
independence the two would remain
separate thereafter with haiti briefly
becoming an empire again and the
dominican republic falling to a spanish
invasion in 1861 this was because the
united states monroe doctrine which
forbid europeans from retaking their old
colonies was somewhat harder to enforce
at this time it didn't matter though
because the dominicans soon revolted and
kicked the spanish out and both parts of
the islands remained as independent
republics thereafter that was until the
early 20th century haiti was still
paying off its debts to france from the
napoleonic era and combined with
expensive wars and general mismanagement
the country had become quite poor
haiti's issues meant that it couldn't
repay some of his debts to an american
bank which meant that it was time for
intervention the united states invaded
the country in 1915 to force through
debt repayment and protect american
interests there the next year the u.s
friendly dominican government was
overthrown and since u.s marines were in
the area in they went both nations were
thus occupied and run by the same
country until the u.s left the dominican
republic in 1924 and haiti in 1934 and
thereafter both haitian and dominican
independence was restored and hispaniola
would remain divided i hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patrons james bissonette kelly money
maker skye chappelle caution wolf jerry
lamdin jordan longley adam stalter
marcus arsenault wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod d martin words about books
podcast captain cydog gustav swan marvin
castle common yoon winston k wood
bugilly wiggly daniel to be in miss iset
matthew shipley aaron the white corey
turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski schuenin spinning three
plates and charles the first